[Music]
having some vision issues what are you
doing the retinas becoming detached and
then the cataract removal surgery so I
mean I'm I've dealt with a lot of stuff
and so it's I'm okay like I'm deal with
it every day I'll never be able to see
how the right eye but the left I mean
I'm seeing what I can see right now it
doesn't make you feel self-conscious how
do you feel I'm so independent like I
can't I'm not able to clean mom house
I'm not able to I'm able to bathe myself
you know do it you're doing the normal
physical things but like cleaning your
house breeding your mouth being able to
pay your own bills like that cuz that
kind of that kind of independency that
I've lost we knew a long time ago this
isn't like friends like oh my god how do
you deal with it so good because we knew
very very young I knew that I was gonna
go blind by the time I was like 30 to 35
and one week became blind it wasn't a
big issue for me and the kids so it was
like a safe we knew this because I was
born with cataracts so you're having a
little bit of roll where we're doing
this pageant together and then also
you're kind of having to take care of
mom a little bit now how does that fit
over you she's always yelling at me like
Alana I want to go dis where yeah I want
to go here like when the mail comes in I
want to read the mail immediately and
then I can when you say like your kids
are telling you so is that kind of how
you know they support you and how you
support your mama literally describing
you know what you would see like you
actually described everything they're
like sure like what is that like it's a
great plan with a pink leaf on the other
side like you have to literally describe
everything does this mean you'll lose
your vision in both eyes I've no vision
in the right eye never will a bad loss
that like I feel ready that I went blind
in my right eye will here comes honey
boo boo boo I went blind in my left eye
when I'm with your front hot I just got
to hit reality TV shows on true
different networks am i it's gonna be a
mind-blowing you just ah blowing it's a
lot to deal with does that scare you to
think about that future for your mom hey
kind of does he's just like well like I
like I deliver for life so I'll have
like graduation
like so many things coming up and
there's a possibility that she won't be
able to see me like walk across the
stage do so I was just her graduated in
college back in May I wasn't able to see
that and you have your granddaughter now
and you're said she's kind of badly yeah
so I don't see that I'm gonna get
emotional that's yeah seeing Ella she
gets so upset because you're just like I
can't see her yeah I can see the shadow
every but I can't make her out yes for
me it's an emotional light just thinking
about it I do think that's why people
relate to somebody because you share so
much of your life very much and you're
so real about it and I'm sure that it
makes people feel connected to you
yes that's what I'm a lot of people say
about us is it we represent the crazy
dysfunctional side up America is this
true
[Music]
[Applause]